[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und christian sievers hallo und
guten abend hinein mit schönen grüßen
aus dem kreml hat russland seine
erdgaslieferungen nach bulgarien und
polen gestoppt es sind schöne grüße auch
richtung deutschland an die adresse der
bundesregierung die ja gerade daran
arbeitet all die jahre extreme
abhängigkeit von russischer energie
irgendwie zurück zu drehen um dann
irgendwann auf solche
erpressungsversuche reagieren zu können
wie etwa die polen die sagen wir sind
vorbereitet
wir in deutschland sind nicht wirklich
vorbereitet allein die aussicht dass
kein gas mehr kommen könnte bereitet
großen teilen der deutschen industrie
manager schlaflose nächte der
bundeswirtschaftsminister sieht das land
dagegen langsam auf einem guten weg und
muss gleichzeitig das gefürchtete r wort
in den mund nehmen wenn das gas jetzt
aus bliebe dann rutsche deutschland in
die rezession christiane hübscher mit
mehr als szenario oft diskutiert für die
ersten europäer nun realität in polen
und bulgarien kommt seit heute kein gas
aus russland mehr an beide länder waren
gewarnt und vorbereitet putin bestraft
sie dafür dass sie ihre lieferungen
nicht in rubel bezahlen wollten
russland hat diesmal die grenze des gas
imperialismus noch einen schritt weiter
verschoben so der polnische
regierungschef
bulgarien wird nicht verhandeln unter
druck und mit gesenktem kopf so der
energieminister bulgarien ist nicht
käuflich
nicht nur der deutsche bundespräsident
gerade auf staatsbesuch in der slowakei
wird deutlich das ist ein regelbruch
seitens muss und das ist an der pressung
versucht den kann man nicht einfach
hinnehmen gegen den muss man sich zu wir
sitzen bei der kamm saisonsieg aber es
ist keine überraschung dass der kreml
versucht uns mit fossilen energien zu
erpressen
auch robert habeck wird kalt erwischt
eigentlich will der
bundeswirtschaftsminister die
frühjahrsprojektion zur konjunktur
vorstellen das an sich wäre schon
dramatisch genug wir sind vor ein paar
monaten davon ausgegangen dass wir eine
erholte wirtschaft in diesem jahr
erleben werden mit einem großen
wachstums schritt den wir mit 3,6
prozent beziffert haben heute senken wir
die prognose um 14 prozent auf 2,2 pa
weg bereitet die deutschen vor auf eine
inflationsrate von gut 6 prozent in
diesem jahr wegen corona wegen des
krieges fehlender rohstoffe gestört der
lieferketten konservativ geschätzt diese
2,2 prozent wachstum sind ohne energie
embargo oder blockade in der
gaslieferung
prognostiziert wenn diese dazu käme
hätten wir eine rezession in deutschland
wie wahrscheinlich ist das anders als
bulgarien und polen hat deutschland seit
wochen ein zweitkonto bei der
gazprombank wo die euro in rubel
umgerechnet werden um putins forderungen
zu erfüllen wenn es doch passiert
bleiben privatkunden vorerst geschützt
was er würde es für die industrie
bedeuten das ist die millionen dollar
frage aber ein kurzfristiger schneller
umfassender lieferstopp oder ein embargo
ist wirtschaftlich nicht handhabbar die
deutschen gasspeicher haben sich zwar
seit kriegsbeginn wieder etwas gefüllt
von 30 auf jetzt 35 prozent die
versorgungssicherheit ist aktuell
gewährleistet beim branchenverband aber
bleiben sie nervös wir stehen jetzt mit
35 prozent zu diesem zeitpunkt im jahr
relativ gut da sehr spannend zu
beobachten wird aber sein wie im mai die
füllung tatsächlich passieren werden
welche initiativen durch die branchen
durch die händler ergriffen werden damit
die durch das speicher gesetz
vorgegebenen füllstände bis zum november
90 prozent dann auch wirklich erreicht
werden der krieg der nun auch via
gaspipeline geführt wird aber wie hat
robert habeck heute gesagt bange machen
gilt nicht
kein gas mehr für polen und bulgarien
und zwar ab sofort das ist ja zumindest
eines nämlich ein klares zeichen dass
die jahrzehntelange gewissheit nicht
mehr gilt die hieß was immer passiert
auch im kalten krieg das russische gas
das fließt es ist definitiv anlass für
plan b szenarien frank umbach ist der
was wäre wenn experte für
energiesicherheit erforscht an der uni
bonn und ist jetzt bei uns gute nannte
rombach
jahren haben da sie das was ist denn
wenn russland heute abend sagen sollte
wir liefern jetzt auch kein gas mehr
nach deutschland
dann hätten wir zwar nicht sofort ein
problem das hat herr habe auch immer
wieder in den letzten wochen wiederholt
weil wir noch gas in den gasspeicher
haben die sind auch wieder ein bisschen
aufgefüllt worden und wir gehen jetzt in
die sommerperiode hinein wo der
heizbedarf eher gering ist aber ungefähr
ab juli kommt mir dann wiederum in
dieses hase wo wir ja den gasspeicher
für die winterzeit ausfüllen müssen und
da haben wir das problem dass wir einen
globalen gasmarkt eben haben wo es kein
überangebot gibt so wie das noch bis
2020 war sondern ein gas angebot das
gerade für die globale gasversorgung
eben reich deswegen sprechen wir nicht
mehr von einem käufer sondern von einem
verkäufermarkt und insoweit gibt es
dadurch erhebliche probleme kurzfristig
für die winterzeit an zusätzliches gas
zu kommen
ein zusätzliches gas zu kommen aber was
heißt das denn für uns alle hier in
deutschland für die industrie die ja
immer noch wirkliche
katastrophenszenarien aufmacht
und ich teile nicht alle diese
katastrophen szenarien die da im moment
gemalt werden aber fakt ist auf jeden
fall wir haben auf der einen seite die
abhängigkeit von russland in der tat
schon reduziert von 35 auf 35 prozent
das ist innerhalb der kurzen zeit schon
ganz beachtlich aber wir stoßen eben
dann an der weiten zuge dieser weiteren
reduzierung der abhängigkeit von
russland doch an unsere grenzen und
deswegen ist ungefähr ab dem sommer
keineswegs eben gesichert dass wir ohne
weiteres die kompletten 155 milliarden
kubikmeter hat nicht nur für deutschland
sondern wir müssen immer die eu auch
sehen tatsächlich kompensiert werden
können die abhängigkeit reduziert von 55
auf 35 prozent meinten sie gerade in dem
ich an der umbau dann schließt sich
jetzt die frage an wer müsste denn
zuerst drosseln wenn das gas nicht mehr
erreicht bislang hieß es ja immer die
privathaushalte auf jeden fall nicht
jetzt meldet sich heute der
aufsichtsratsvorsitzende des
energieversorgers e.on karl ludwig kley
und er fordert bei der gasversorgung
vorfahrt für die industrie die politik
solle sehr ernsthaft darüber nachdenken
ob sie die reihenfolge nicht umdreht und
erst bei privaten abschaltet und dann
bei der industrie denkbar für sie
einen der pauschalität sicherlich nicht
aber man kann natürlich überlegen ob
beispielsweise irgendwelche private
sauna ist wirklich dann geheizt werden
müssen im winter oder nicht also es gibt
schon erhebliche einsparpotenziale gibt
es aber auch bei der industrie auf wir
müssen immer daran denken dass wir
historisch gesehen keine erfahrung mit
einem solchen erdgasimporte oder
exportstopp in dem fall von russland arm
und wir alle relativ unvorbereitet sind
in den letzten wochen und sind
notfallpläne erarbeitet worden das mache
die gasindustrie sicherlich schon
bekannt aber für viele andere industrien
die an der weiteren lieferkette hängen
für die war die situation komplett neu
und die hatten der vergangenheit
jedenfalls weiß keine konkreten
notfallpläne dann dreht man herum
braucht zum schluss des spiels
vielleicht nochmal kurzum was wären denn
die folgen für russland wenn russland
die gaslieferungen stoppen würde klar
ist dann wäre erstens kein geld mehr da
es würde kein geld mehr reinkommt aber
zweitens gibt es offenbar auch noch
enorme weitere probleme nämlich für die
russen selbst
das ist das ist richtig also bei den
diskussionen wird zum wissen übersehen
so waren die diskussionen der letzten
woche wo man häufig argumentiert hat
dass der ölexport mehr geld für den
staatshaushalt generiert das übersieht
so ein bisschen die problematik dass die
erdgaspreise ja dramatisch angezogen
haben und es übersieht zweitens das
faktum dass gazprom in der vergangenheit
als der haupt exporteur von erdgas
überhaupt keine steuern in den
staatshaushalt bezahlt hat sondern
infrastrukturen wie bei den olympischen
spielen in sotschi finanziert hat
tatsächlich würde ein erdgas exportstopp
oder importstopp von unserer seite die
russische wirtschaft und den russischen
staatshaushalt viel mehr treffend und
zwar auch deswegen weil die
erdölexporte größtenteils oder zumindest
zu einem teil eben immer noch auf den
weltmarkt gebracht werden kann über
tanker bei den erst gab's da es exporten
ist das überhaupt nicht der fall david
in russland auf seine erdgas sitzen
bleiben und auch bohrlöcher zu schließen
beispielsweise die produktion
abzustellen ist in einer permafrost
rektoren aktes fast unmöglich und so
weiter trifft der erdgas export die
russische wirtschaft tatsächlich viel
mehr als der
erdölexport wie viele immer
offensichtlich noch glauben sagt frank
umbach experte für energiesicherheit
herum braucht danke ihnen für das
gespräch heute abend
100 milliarden euro für die army da
dürfte vielen bundeswehrangehörigen die
ohren klingeln eine armee die knapsen
musste jahrelang und an der geknipst
wurde steht jetzt plötzlich im
mittelpunkt auch finanziell aber und das
ist das große aber noch sind die 100
milliarden nicht auf dem tisch und schon
gar nicht in den kasernen angekommen sie
sind aktuell streitthema im parlament
dass sich etwas ändern muss an der
ausstattung der bundeswehr an der
verteidigungsfähigkeit deutschlands für
diese aussage gäbe es locker eine satte
mehrheit im bundestag bei der frage nach
dem wie aber knirscht es erheblich
thomas reichert es beginnt erstmal
überraschend harmonisch die union einigt
sich mit der ampel auf einen gemeinsamen
antrag zur lieferung schwerer waffen in
die ukraine und gibt damit auch den
versuch auf die regierungskoalition zu
spalten mit einem eigenen antrag wir
wollen gemeinsam mit den ampel
fraktionen die entscheidung mittragen
das schwere waffen an die ukraine
geliefert werden das ist unser
gemeinsamer auftrag und für frieden in
europa zu sorgen bei waffen für die
bundeswehr aber ist es vorbei mit der
einigkeit scholz hat eine zeitenwende
versprochen ein sondervermögen über 100
milliarden euro verankert im grundgesetz
dafür wirbt die ampel um die stimmen der
union
es geht nicht um eine militarisierung
der außenpolitik aber um eines man muss
kämpfen können um nicht kämpfen zu
müssen und deshalb muss die bundeswehr
ertüchtigt werden aus sicht der ampel
geht es dabei auch immer um versäumnisse
der union die in den letzten 16 jahren
die verteidigungs minister oder
ministerinnen stellte wir haben zum
beispiel auf dem papier
350 schützenpanzer puma
davon sind tatsächlich
150 einsatzbereit beim kampfhubschrauber
tiger sitzt nicht anders aus von 51
maschinen können gerade mal neun abheben
schuld an diesem zustand aber will die
union nicht alleine sein es wird viel
mit dem finger auf andere gezeigt wir
schauen uns das mit selbstkritik an aber
hier stehen herr kollege tor so viele
glashäuser um da würde jeder
gärtnereibetrieb vorüber sein wir stehen
sie setzten auch in einem glashaus die
union jedenfalls kündigt an dass sie den
gesetzentwurf der ampel für das
sondervermögen so nicht zustimmen werde
das ziel in zukunft zwei prozent der
wirtschaftsleistung für verteidigung
auszugeben werde nicht festgeschrieben
und das sei nicht klar ob die 100
milliarden wirklich nur für die
bundeswehr verwendet würden es geht bei
diesem sondervermögen nicht um
humanitäre hilfe die ist absolut
notwendig dafür stellen wir aber einen
ergänzungs haushalt auf es geht hier um
harte
sicherheitsmaßnahmen im sinne der
vernetzten sicherheit
im ringen zwischen ampel und union um
die größte finanzspritze in der
geschichte der bundeswehr spielen andere
fast nur nebenrollen die afg kritisiert
dass damit sonder schulden außerhalb des
haushalts entstünden die linke das
überhaupt so viel geld für verteidigung
ausgegeben werde die bundeswehr ist
nicht wegen zu wenig geld kaum
einsatzfähig sondern wegen des
grottenschlechten
denn dieses schwarze loch in dieser
sprache oder drei weitere milliarden
steuergelder versenkt werden nein ampel
und union wollen nun weiter verhandeln
so gewaltig die summe ist um die es geht
so groß ist auch der druck sich am ende
doch irgendwie zu einigen
cdu chef friedrich merz ist der
oppositionsführer und jetzt bei uns in
der sendung guten abend herr merz
genannter siegers die bundesregierung
ist ja ob der brisanten weltlage nicht
unbedingt zu beneiden wären sie jetzt
gerne kanzler
ich bin oppositionsführer und diese
rolle völlig hoffentlich aus und wenn es
geht suchen wir auch gemeinsamkeiten mit
der bundesregierung und auch mit dem
bundeskanzler wenn es geht haben sie
gesagt sie wollten die bundeswehr
zeitenwende des kanzlers unterstützen
auch gegen widerstände haben sie im
bundestag am 27 februar gesagt dann
haben sie erst widerstände gemacht und
jetzt doch ein gemeinsamer antrag
zumindest über waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine können sie den bundeskanzler
verstehen der ja sagt deutschland darf
auf keinen fall kriegspartei werden wir
müssen einen dritten weltkrieg
verhindern
ja ja sie was darüber sind wir uns ja
auch einig niemand will den dritten
weltkrieg und niemand will eine atomare
eskalation ich halte im übrigen auch
diese drohung damit für nicht angemessen
wir sprechen hier über das recht auf
selbstverteidigung der ukraine und wir
ringen um die frage wie weit wir der
ukraine dabei auch nicht nur aber auch
mit waffenlieferungen helfen können und
dazu gibt es jetzt einen gemeinsamen
entschließungsantrag morgen im deutschen
bundestag begrüßte das ausdrücklich wir
haben den vorschlag ursprünglich alleine
gemacht die ampelkoalition hat jetzt
einen eigenen vorschlag eingebracht und
jetzt machen wir einen gemeinsamen und
das ist eine gute lösung dann bleibt bei
einem anderen wichtigen thema noch viele
fragen offen nämlich dem großen
milliarden paket für die bundeswehr als
opposition kann man jetzt natürlich
sagen wir machen eine eigene agenda wir
versuchen offen zu legen dass es
uneinigkeit gibt in der regierung ist
kann man machen muss man aber nicht
unbedingt vielleicht auch nicht gerade
in krisenzeiten für dieses land
zumindest bekommt die bundeswehr dadurch
ja keinen hubschrauber extra also
zunächst einmal herr sievers ist es
unsere aufgabe als opposition
auch auf widersprüche und auf streit in
der koalition hinzuweisen wir sind uns
hier schon unserer verantwortung bewusst
und diese verantwortung nehmen wir auch
war aber wir lassen es nicht zu dass die
regierung definiert wie die
oppositionsarbeit zu laufen hat das
entscheiden wir und das urteil darüber
gibt auch nicht die regierung ab sondern
das geben allenfalls die wählerinnen und
wähler in deutschland ab und wenn wir
das sozusagen vor die klammer gestellt
haben dann sind wir uns in den
sachfragen an der einen oder anderen
stelle einig und an der einen oder
anderen stelle noch nicht einig darüber
reden wir mit die bunten mit der
bundesregierung die bundesregierung
möchte etwas von uns sie möchte unsere
zustimmung zu einer grundgesetzänderung
und das ist keine triviale sache sondern
wir reden hier über 100 milliarden euro
neuer schulden die in deutschland
aufgenommen werden sollen und dass das
vernünftig gemacht wird und dass das
auch so gemacht wird dass das irgendwann
getilgt werden kann das ist unsere
gemeinsame verantwortung und dieser
gemeinsamen verantwortung stellen wir
uns auch das ist keine triviale sache
haben sie absolut recht es gibt uns sehr
sehr sehr viel geld trotzdem wenn sie
jetzt nicht zustimmen dann scheitert das
ganze und können sie es sich leisten
dass es am ende heißt friedrich merz ist
derjenige der der bundeswehr das geld
verweigert wir wollen der bundeswehr das
geld nicht verweigern aber der normale
weg wäre dass dies im normalen haushalt
abgebildet wird wir wissen dass auch wir
in unserer regierungsverantwortung dies
in den letzten jahren nicht ausreichend
getan haben aber wenn die koalition
jetzt einen anderen weg gehen will und
dieser weg nur über eine
grundgesetzänderung möglich wäre und ich
spreche hier bewusst im konjunktiv dann
müssen wir den weg gemeinsam gehen und
dann kann es nicht sein dass die
regierung hier etwas vorlegt und uns
sagt ihr müsst jetzt hier ohne wenn und
aber zustimmen aber das ist mein herz
ist ein einsamer auf erreichen denen ich
sind wir dann auch bereit zu erfüllen
ich muss aber noch mal fragen weil
dieses diese einzelheiten verstehen doch
die bürgerinnen und bürger gar nicht
mehr so genau am ende bleibt doch dann
hängen die cdu/csu friedrich merz haben
verhindert dass es jetzt deutlich mehr
geld 100 milliarden für die bundeswehr
gibt
und das will friedrich merz und das will
auch die unionsfraktion nicht verhindern
aber wir wollen es so machen dass es
genauso ist wie der bundeskanzler dass
in seiner regierungserklärung am 27
februar gesagt hat 100 milliarden
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr das
ist möglich aber bitte dann auch
dauerhaft mehr als zwei prozent des
bruttoinlandproduktes unseres landes für
die verteidigung und das ist gegenwärtig
in den vorschlägen der bundesregierung
nicht abgebildet wir wollen nicht mehr
aber auch nicht weniger als das was der
bundeskanzler selbst vor acht wochen in
seiner regierungserklärung im deutschen
bundestag gesagt hat das klingt ja so
als ob sie sich am ende doch einigen
oder wir wollen uns einigen herr sievers
aber wir sind von einer einigung noch
weit entfernt und ich will es wieder
holen uns das einfach vorzulegen so wie
das jetzt im regierungsentwurf gemacht
worden ist und wir gesagt bekommen friss
oder stirb das ist keine art der
zusammenarbeit und diese zusammenarbeit
wird es dann auch nicht geben jetzt
haben sie vorher schon angekündigt nur
mit so vielen eigenen stimmen also aus
der union dafür zu stimmen wie die
mehrheit unbedingt braucht um
tatsächlich dann diese
grundgesetzänderung durchbringen zu
können das ist sozusagen die idee
abweichler die möglicherweise aus den
ampel reinkommen zu entlarven das ist
natürlich eine oppositions taktik die
sie anwenden können aber mal angenommen
sie werden am ende alle überzeugt auch
in der union von dem von der idee müssen
dann nicht auch alle mitstimmen können
sie sich dann solche taktischen
geschichten leisten sie was das
entscheiden wir wenn wir das ergebnis
auf dem tisch liegen haben und jetzt
will ich mal eine kurze historische
parallele wählen wir haben heute den 27
april 2022 heute genau auf den tag genau
vor 50 jahren hat das konstruktive
misstrauensvotum der union gegen willy
brandt gegeben und herbert wehner der
damalige fraktionsvorsitzende der spd
hat alle abgeordneten der spd fraktion
bis auf die mitglieder der
bundesregierung aus dem saal heraus
befohlen die durften alle nicht mit
abstimmen weil er sicherstellen wollte
dass kein einziger aus den eigenen
reihen der abgeordneten
für rainer barzel im deutschen bundestag
stimmt also wenn wir das heute in ganz
kleinem maßstab noch einmal erwägen dann
hat das durchaus eine tradition im
deutschen parlamentarismus also
historische parallelen und es geht auch
um letztlich um ein historisches paket
für die bundeswehr friedrich merz der
oppositionschef ist danke hin fürs
gespräch
ich danke ihnen sehr
und das gespräch haben wir aus
termingründen kurz vor dieser sendung
aufgezeichnet so wir bleiben noch bei
wichtigen und zugleich teuren
entscheidungen der regierung heizt das
bundeskabinett hat den von
finanzminister lindner vorgelegten
ergänzungs haushalt mit fast 40
milliarden euro zusätzliche schulden auf
den weg gebracht mit dem geld soll vor
allem ein entlastungspaket finanziert
werden deswegen der stark gestiegenen
energiepreise beschlossen wurde
vorgesehen sind eine energiepreis
pauschale von 300 euro brutto für
erwerbstätige eine einmalige kindergeld
anhebung von 100 euro pro kind ein tank
rabatt ein liter benzin soll 30 cent
weniger kosten diesel 14 cent weniger
und für drei monate ein billig ticket im
nahverkehr für neun euro pro monat
bundesbauministerium geiwitz hält trotz
der probleme der branche infolge des
ukraine kriegs an ihrem ziel fest
jährlich 400.000 neue wohnungen zu
schaffen dieser ambitioniert aber die
wohnungen würden nicht zuletzt wegen der
geflüchteten aus der ukraine dringend
benötigt sagte gallwitz bei einem
treffen mit spitzenvertretern des
baugewerbes in berlin die bauwirtschaft
äußerte sich skeptisch und verwies auf
lieferketten probleme und hohe
energiekosten
zudem müssten genehmigungs und
vergabeverfahren beschleunigt werden
die eu kommission hat heute offiziell
ein verfahren gegen ungarn gestartet
wegen möglicher verstöße gegen
rechtsstaatliche prinzipien mit dem
sogenannten eu rechtsstaatsmission ismus
könnte ungarn am ende des verfahrens
eine kürzung von eu geldern drohen
zunächst einmal kann budapest nun zu den
vorwürfen stellung beziehen
in myanmar hat ein von der militär unter
kontrollierten gericht die entmachtete
regierungschef in sanssouci zu weiteren
fünf jahren haft verurteilt wegen
angeblicher korruption
die 76 jährige wies die vorwürfe als
absurd zurück die internationale
gemeinschaft forderte ihre sofortige
freilassung
es ist bereits das zweite urteil gegen
unseren ski und weitere
korruptionsverfahren stehen noch bevor
seit dem militärputsch im vergangenen
jahr steht die
friedensnobelpreisträgerin unter
hausarrest
manchmal ist auch das was man nicht
macht ein zeichen der bundeskanzler ist
nach der debatte im bundestag wir haben
ja gerade darüber berichtet schnell los
in den regierungsflieger auf zur ersten
asienreise und eben nicht nach china wo
angela merkel zwölfmal war immer mit
einer großen wirtschaftsdelegation im
gefolge olaf scholz fliegt über peking
hinweg nach japan das hat mit neuen
gemeinsamkeiten zu tun und mit
gemeinsamen gegnern ulf röller berichtet
das meer schaut so friedlich aus sagte
erzähler aber die welt verändert sich
den frieden zu bewahren dafür arbeitet
die marine mit solchen militär videos
wirkt die japanische regierung für ihre
auf rüstungs pläne das land erlebt eine
zeitenwende
sie ruhig schieber war japanischer
verteidigungsminister er ist eine der
prominentesten stimmen die eine
aufrüstung fordern
es ist war der krieg in der ukraine
rüttelt wohl die bevölkerung was sie
denkt darüber nach wie sie das land
besser verteidigen kann
die allianz zwischen dem chinesischen
präsidenten ski und putin verunsichert
die region japan fürchtet den mächtigen
nachbarn china und diskutiert intensiv
über angriffswaffen
jedes land ob china oder ein anderes das
weiß dass wir angriffswaffen besitzen
und dass wir uns wehren können wird sein
verhalten anpassen
der abwurf der atombombe in hiroshima
hat die militärpolitik des landes
jahrzehntelang geprägt japan gab sich
eine pazifistische verfassung die jeden
militärischen angriff verbietet der neue
premierminister key china ist bereit ist
zu ende er sucht die nähe zum militär
will das recht haben auch offensiv
waffen einzusetzen auch gespürt die
zeitenwende
china wird versuchen sich von der neuen
deutschen sicherheitspolitik inspirieren
zu lassen um das gleiche argument
vorzubringen dass japan sich in einer
ähnlichen situation befindet und
anfangen sollte ernsthaft aufzurüsten
presidential wird zunehmend als
bedrohung wahrgenommen japan streitet
sich mit china um ein paar inseln im
pazifik
nordkoreas diktator kim jong un baut
weiter sein atombombe nacional aus das
alles führt zu einem wettrüsten in der
region
um konservative regierungspartei ldp
will den verteidigungshaushalt auf zwei
prozent des bruttoinlandsproduktes
erhöhen was einer verdoppelung
gleichkommt
japaner 2020 mehr als 45 milliarden euro
für das militär ausgegeben das aufrüsten
stößt auf den widerstand der
friedensbewegung das trauma des zweiten
weltkrieges beeinflusst bis heute die
japanische gesellschaft
nie mehr krieg das wurde uns beigebracht
mein ganzes leben kämpfe ich für diese
lehre
zeitenwende auch in japan der
angriffskrieg der russen beschleunigt
ein weltweites aufrüsten
[Musik]
und jetzt nochmal zum anfang unserer
sendung und noch mal zu heiß und nochmal
zur wirtschaftsminister harbeck der
heute wie schon angesprochen auch die
frühjahrsprojektion der regierung zur
wirtschaftsentwicklung vorgestellt hat
demnach wird ein wachstum von nur noch
22 erwartet frank bethmann an der börse
wie sind die reaktionen darauf sollten
wir eine prognose von so viel
unsicherheit geprägt krieg fehlende
teile inflation der deutsche
wachstumsmotor ist kräftig ins stottern
geraten der industrieverband bdi betonte
heute eine kurzfristige erholung sei
nicht in sicht es gebe eine doppelte
krise hohe energiepreise und
unterbrochene internationale
lieferketten wegen der erneuten störung
des container seeverkehrs aus china
bremsen die konjunktur
ernüchterung auch beim dihk niemand weil
es aktuell wie tief die krise unsere
wirtschaft noch treffen wird bei allen
kommentaren schwingt mit die weitere
wirtschaftliche entwicklung wird
maßgeblich von der dauer des krieges in
der ukraine abhängen und von der frage
ob russland tatsächlich ernst macht und
den gashahn zudreht wie viel weiteres
wachstum das kosten könnte darüber kann
nur spekuliert werden noch aber kann die
deutsche wirtschaft zulegen allerdings
weniger als gedacht war man anfang des
jahres noch von 3,6 prozent ausgegangen
sind es jetzt eben nur noch 2,2 prozent
wichtig für die verbraucher die
regierung rechnet für das gesamtjahr mit
einer inflationsrate von
6,1 prozent ein grund dafür die rasant
gestiegenen energiepreise gerade die
haben die verbraucherlaune in
deutschland inzwischen auf ein
rekordtief gedrückt zu dem ergebnis
kamen heute das größte deutsche
marktforschungsinstitut die gfk in
nürnberg frank bethmann vielen dank
und die zahlen vom lotto am mittwoch sie
lauten wie immer ohne gewähr 3 17 19 25
40 46 die superzahl 8 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 55 7
eine neue crew aus je zwei
astronautinnen und astronauten ist auf
dem weg zur internationalen raumstation
die trägerrakete des privaten
raumfahrtunternehmen spacex hob in der
nacht vom weltraumzentrum cape canaveral
ab die besatzung die fünf monate lang
auf der iss bleiben soll löst dort den
deutschen matthias maurer und drei
seiner kollegen ab
so wie unsere welt von der erde aus
betrachtet aussah das haben wir eben
jetzt gezeigt in diesem heute-journal
danke für ihr interesse und um 0.45
meldet sich dann christopher wehrmann
mit dem heute-journal update von uns
allen hier ein angenehmer abend wieder
sind
[Musik]
die und herzlich willkommen zum wetter
ein kurzer rückblick auf den märz das
war ja der fünftwärmste märz global
gesehen aber lokal war es durchaus
deutlich wärmer zum beispiel richtung
indien und pakistan hier
temperaturabweichungen deutlich über dem
normal und da ist ja derzeit eine
massive hitzewelle zu gange es zeigt
also diese karte zeigt dass es also
schon vorher im märz deutlich zu warm
war schauen wir auf das wetter in
deutschland und da haben wir es mit
diesem umfangreichen hoch zu tun auf
seiner ostseite kommt kühle luft voran
und das spüren wir besonders an den
küsten einige wolken sind auch dabei zum
beispiel in der kommenden nacht nach
osten hin also etwas dichter bewölkt als
im westen und im süden teilweise bildet
sich nebel vor allem in gewässernähe und
das bei tiefsten temperaturen von null
grad an den alpen ein grad im vogtland
und im nordwesten sieben grad etwas
milder dann richtung rhein main gebiet
morgenland viel sonnenschein vor allem
in den westlichen landesteilen oder auch
im süden sonst sind auch mal einige
dichte wolken dabei bei insgesamt
trockenes wetter temperaturen erreichen
höchstwerte an den küsten von 12 bis 14
grad je merkt man durchaus als etwas
kühlere luft heran strömt zu als im
gegensatz zum südwesten 20 bis 23 grad
hier ist es also am wärmsten morgen die
nächsten tage am freitag ist es trocken
aber die wolken werden lichter 11 bis 22
grad und spätestens ab samstag gibt es
dann schauer und gewitter im süden und
es ist dann etwas kühler ein schöner
abend